good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast happy Thursday hope everyone's
having a fabulous Thursday I know I am
because not only is it the hers day it
is the final show before I come and join
you in Florida I'm on my way
um on my way that and trbc merch drop I
mean what more could you want redheads
merch dropped this morning go and get
yours I'm wearing my third sweatshirt of
the week this is a really lovely number
it's Ivory I think in some of the
pictures it looked a little more white
but it's like a creamy bone and it has
our little gorgeous Scholastic logo on
the left breast and I'm just feeling so
Scholastic I love a left breast logo you
know I really do love to see it so this
collection is so sickening and it's vile
you'd be remiss devastated and
heartbroken if you didn't go check it
out at shopmorningtoast.com we have four
sweatshirts the other sweatshirt that I
didn't wear this week is just the maroon
crew neck but in a different
sweatshirt material because the last one
was super thick we launched it in like
February this is more of a light
autumnal sweater and then we have a gray
long sleeve we have mug we have a case
we have hats uh two hats and one large
tote bag for all of your books
so important that you have a tote in
which to carry your books yes to and
from the bookstore
um well that's great congratulations on
another fabulous launch over at trbc
we're we're always rooting for you here
at the toast thank you I definitely can
feel the enthusiasm from corporate and
it's really appreciated
that's funny
um so yes I am also we're recording a
little early today because I gotta go my
nieces my nephews they need me
um and I gotta go because I'm an auntie
on the go you know you are and also
Bryce needs his strikes
streis is here streis is coming with me
I'm
like I couldn't sleep last night so
excited to see the kids like the way I'm
going to attack rolled is not even
normal and honestly just say a prayer
for Kayla because once I get within
Arm's Reach like she's done she's done
she'll never work in this town again the
thing about rolls is that he is so
looking forward to being attacked like
he just wants action like you couldn't
attack him hard enough like he says more
and the thing is is that it wasn't until
Olivia just gave birth that I really
truly realized how like rolled is not a
baby anymore like he could take it like
I thought rolled was so small and then I
saw a picture of him next to Olivia's
new baby and I'm like oh this kid is
enormous he can take whatever I throw at
him like I will be when I say tackling
him it's gonna be a tackle to end all
tackles O.J Simpson uh Tom Brady they're
gonna not gonna know what hit him it's
gonna be such a big tackle
okay I will tell him to brace himself no
when I tell him tell him and toj's
coming when I first met Olivia's baby
then I came home and I saw mine I was
like you're a grown man no and it's the
way that world is the biggest child on
the planet
like he's eaten good mama's mama's teeth
and then Mama's puree he's even good
puree he's still on his puree grind he
eats Gourmet he eats better and nicer
than I do like more about of course like
more balanced meals just like gorgeous
gorgeous food yeah no that makes sense
we do start our dates together with each
having oatmeal he has baby oatmeal I
have the grown oatmeal no like there are
truly no words for how excited I am like
the plane ride it's gonna be so long
because you know when you're really
looking forward to something like the
plane ride takes forever yeah and lets
me not forget like The Strife Brothers
will be reunited and nature will be
healed and Theo needs a trip you know he
really really is a lot going on he needs
a trip down south you know he needs to
decompress Bryce needs a friend and last
night like I was trying to tell him I
always tell him whenever something
exciting has happened I'm like I Promise
You Adventure is coming like mommy and
mommy never lies never never so I know
he knows that today something is in
store but he doesn't know what
I am a little bummed because I was like
secretly hoping Olivia would keep them
legs closed for a few more days
um because Spritz is starting a
Halloween party tomorrow in the city and
like everyone's going and I'm like
having a little fomo like it's kind of
annoying
um
and The Toasters can go if you guys want
there I think their tickets still
available just go to like the Spritz or
the Hampton Water Instagram or there's a
link on my Instagram too it's gonna be
the party of the Year honestly so I'm a
little fomo even though I didn't have a
costume and I was getting like
Pittsville trying to come like I can
only Channel my Creative Energy for one
costume per Halloween and I gave it to
the toaster coming October 31st of
course no I think that that's for the
best the party does look so much fun and
um jealous of everyone who gets to go
speaking of Spritz and in my influencers
chat people were like who's going so
like everyone's going and it's like it's
my party I'm spritzing like I'm not even
going and what if they do like a group
costume without shut up stop like you
know me I'll die
speaking of Spritz yesterday got
something so exciting because when I did
my Georgia meet and greet I got the most
amazing gifts from The Toasters who
showed up and I flew in and flew out I
didn't even bring a suitcase a little
one I just bought a handbag so I
couldn't take everything with me so
everything was shipped to me and I got
the package yesterday and like I hadn't
had a chance to like go through every
gift some of them I hadn't even opened
yet and like I was just so touched by
everything that was sent like so many
things that I already knew were coming
that were cracking me up so many people
like got clothes for rolled or like made
cups that's so sweet such cute stuff I
was gonna do like a Haul on my Instagram
story which I still want to do I just
then put all the clothes in the laundry
so I'll have to wait
um but I was just like so touched and
really that's so sweet thoughtful things
that I will use so many Ray dun mugs
like of course a ray done doggy bowl for
Theo when he comes
but I not them thinking of rolled when
like you won't even show them world it's
so sweet and every time someone gives me
something they're like we don't know
what size to get because wait we don't
even know what he looks like yeah but
he's like uh what he goes whatever size
of the month that he is like pretty it
pretty much works
so that he can grow into stuff and it
will last longer but um it's pretty On
Target I would say let me try and help
people visualize what road looks like
okay
first of all sack of potatoes if you
need to know physique like his body's
just like filled with deliciousness
and then face like I just I encourage
you to like look up you know model child
model Gerber baby that's the energy you
get yeah
everyone's perfection
yeah no for sure like who's that I don't
know him
don't know I do see bits of Sac but in
certain photos actually he looks really
wine red but like most of the day he's
really you yeah he looks like his mommy
as he should as he should me him and
Bruno are twins
um we have a Fab show we also have TV
recap yesterday so much TV new episode
of tell me lies and Salt Lake City which
I know you didn't watch so I'll just
touch on briefly and then part two of
The Real Housewives of Beverly Hills
reunion which was
electric yeah it was really good I
watched one and two last night and I was
gonna watch tell me lies but it was like
10 o'clock you should go to sleep like
around 11 but I was like my eyes feel
sleepy I was like no place it go to
sleep [ __ ] the episode like was good
though it was but you know what I I'm
I'm excited to watch it when I don't
have to watch it hastily and I had such
a busy day yesterday I had like hoped to
get more TV done but it just didn't
happen we recorded such a great episode
yesterday for our patreon
um we did of like me interviewing
Claudia with General q a questions that
you guys had for her we did audio and
video it looks just like an episode of
the toast super premium and it's
available at patreon.com the toast
yeah there were some juicy tidbits in
there one there was some Bravo too that
I didn't feel comfortable saying on the
main podcast about bravocon and then
also we had a really in-depth discussion
about the future of girl with no job you
know like I thought it did get me
thinking and a lot of the feedback I got
was people begging not to change it so I
I think I am going to stay where I'm at
but I would love to hear people's
thoughts honestly yeah listen to the
episode so you can understand like what
we're trying to say or what I'm trying
to say I did see people were resistant
but I do think people are resistant to
change of course yeah but I I don't know
okay
so that's a little bit about me
um shall we dive in dive into the fast
five stories that you need to know
also our last episode in front of these
Palm I just want to say I'm not thrilled
with where we landed with that intro
we're still flying the plane it will
come okay I'm not worried I don't need
to make a decision I'm I'm no but we
haven't done the crunch in a few days
like I'm not I'm not thrilled well
that's because like you didn't want to
do the crunch because like you have to
get a no but like I would do it but like
I just haven't felt like it needs like
it's
starting tomorrow will be at my place I
don't even have the crunch so it's gonna
Force us to figure it out okay good
we'll figure it out while we're together
that is a goal for the week how about
that yeah like what have when have we
ever like not had a creative idea like
I'm not worried about us also quick
um update on the show from yesterday
just something that we had to issue a
correction for Jackie and I we're
talking about Matthew Perry and we just
kept saying how like really this man
should write a memoir and it turns out
the interview that he was doing was in
promotion of his Memoir which comes out
November 1st so uh I blame Jackie for
that one but we apologize nonetheless
yeah no that I'll take that one on the
chin um if I didn't have to assign blame
I would blame the Daily Mail because I
didn't want to read the People magazine
article it's like we're sitting down
with Matthew Perry I'm like I want the
highlights which Daily Mail provided but
it wasn't in like the header that it was
like in the for the book maybe if I
scrolled all the way down which perhaps
I should have but those Daily Mail
articles can be long anyways very
lengthy sufficient to say I apologize my
bad
that's okay we all make mistakes
now
let's move on to today's episode which
is sponsored by Lands End if you guys
ever have to work in an uncomfortable
uniform you know that it can really
affect your day or if you're constantly
being disappointed by Cheap pointless
promo products at trade shows and events
you shouldn't just slap your logo on any
old uniform you can create an extension
of your brand that's ready for anything
with custom apparel from Lands End
Business so their quality comfort and
style that you can count on they have
the best in class customer care so you
can let Lands End handle the inventory
while you run your business so if you're
looking to get fully customized clothes
accessories promo products featuring
your logo your colors you can elevate it
with Land's End by their Decades of
experience since 1993 thousands of
businesses businesses excuse me have
relied on Lands End Business to outfit
their employees they offer Timeless
styles that fit every body type with the
widest range of sizes that you'll find
in Brandon apparel you could see your
logo in Vivid colors on t-shirts
outerwear hats mugs water bottles and
more hundreds of products perfect for
any trade show event or holiday gifting
so their uniforms are anything but
routine Lands End Business is one of the
online leader in online supplying of
iconic uniforms for everyone from Top
financial institutions to major airlines
to local mom and pop shops whether
you're a carpet cleaner mechanic moving
company Corner Pizza Shop they have the
uniform that you desire and all of your
needs covered it's so much more than the
same old work polos their customized
uniforms fit the way you work and keep
your employees cool dry and comfortable
their state-of-the-art design and
stitching technology turns your logo
into an instantly recognizable work of
art so there's no more fidgeting with an
itchy work shirt they're premium Fabric
and fit offer all-day comfort that keeps
employees happy and confident so they
also have some of the best customer
service in the business because you can
get email chat and phone support from a
customer service rep eager here to help
every business is treated like a VIP
with lens and business whether you have
five employees or 500 set up an online
store where employees can order the
items they need without worrying about
inventory and of course we have a
discount for you guys and you can see
why companies count on lens and business
go to
business.landsend.com toast use the
promo code toast for 25 off your first
product that's
business.landsend.com toast
promo code toast for 25 off your first
product today's episode is also
sponsored by liquid IV with cooler
weather it makes it easy to miss signs
of dehydration like overheating or
sweating perspiration so that means it's
even more important to keep your body
hydrated liquid ID fuels your well-being
with easy ways to stay hydrated in just
one stick you're getting five essential
vitamins and hydrating two two times
faster than with water alone
whether you're preparing for the day
taking long-haul flights going on
vacation whatever it is liquid IV is an
essential addition to your routine
especially if you have trouble drinking
lots of water myself included
um it's so much smarter to like make
good use of the water that you are
drinking throw a liquid IV in there it's
gonna give you a huge boost of vitamins
but it's also going to hydrate you
better than water alone so if you're not
always the best with remembering to
drink x amount of water per day make
sure you're drinking liquid IV when you
do drink water because you'll be really
happy that you did there's so many
benefits to being hydrated for me when I
get dehydrated I get really lethargic I
get fatigue I get really bad migraines
and when I'm on top of my water schedule
and I'm throwing liquid IV in there I
find that I have a huge decrease in
those symptoms so one stick of liquid IV
into 16 ounces of water is going to
hydrate you two times faster and more
efficiently than water alone it contains
five essential vitamins like B3 B5 B6
B12 and vitamin C it is three times the
electrolytes of a traditional sports
drink so if you are suffering from a
hangover I can't speak from experience
and letting you know that liquid IV is
going to help you enormously it's made
with premium ingredients it's also
non-GMO free of gluten dairy and soy
they're also on a mission to change the
world so to date liquid IV has donated
over 25 million servings in over 50
countries around the world so you know
that your purchase is helping someone in
need grab your liquid IV in bulk
nationwide at Costco or get 15 off when
you go to liquid iv.com toast that's 15
off anything you order when you shop
better hydration today at liquid iv.com
toast also major shout out they have
amazing flavors and they have so many
different flavors so whatever your
palette is you'll find a flavor that you
like they're really good Juliana I drink
a lot of liquid ID
precisely okay ready for our first story
the stories today I would say are unique
love it love it for us but first story
crazy Lana Del Rey's cameras laptop
containing new album and a manuscript
for her book were stolen in a smash and
grab Lana Del Rey pleaded with fans not
to listen to leaked music after some of
her prized items were stolen in a
California Smash and grab the New York
native told fans that thieves took her
backpack containing her computer
multiple hard drives and a camcorder
quote a few months ago I parked my car
in Melrose Place actually Melrose Avenue
in La and I stepped away for a minute
and the one time I left my backpack
inside my car someone broke all the
windows and took it the singer was in
the process of writing a book for
publishing giant Simon and Schuster but
revealed the 200-page manuscript was
among the stolen items as well as a
camcorder filled with Irreplaceable
family footage Theo isn't upset about
this story 200 pages of a movie script
Theo's Tangled in there
rice the rice oh my God you're so
tangled come here there you go oh sweet
boy Thrice Lana said I had to remotely
wipe the computer that had my 200 Page
book for Simon and Chooser which I
didn't have backed up on the cloud and
despite that people are still able to
remotely access my phone and leak our
songs and personal photos I love that
book with that I lost with all of my
heart and put a lot of passion into it
this is [ __ ] horrible people are so
disgusting I like the depths that
Humanity will go to like it never ceases
to amaze me first of all anyone not even
a celebrity just having like your car
broken into like your personal items
stolen is such an invasion of privacy
um obviously we live in a world where
like your phone your laptop it's your
whole [ __ ] life like it's just the
crime in LA in New York like it's so
crazy uh this it ain't right and justice
for Lana Del Rey I'm sure she won't get
any of this back I'm sure photos will
come out music will come out and it's
just horrible and I know people aren't
going to feel bad because like she's
like a rich celebrity but like it's not
right no it's not right and these are
things that are truly Irreplaceable she
lost like old videos from her camcorder
terrible like a book Gone a book oh my
God if I had like finished most of my
manuscript and then
lost it I would be so [ __ ] pissed so
that's so upsetting and so she's asking
her fans not to listen to anything that
leaks and of course like I don't look at
anything that leaks that's personal or
probably of course
um and I I think
people should not do that fandoms are
pretty good about like policing leaks
like I'm obviously you know well into
the Swifty fandom and I believe some of
the Midnight's tracks of leaks but like
people don't share it like if you wanted
to find it it's really [ __ ] hard like
they police that
those like tracks that get that get out
and it's very admirable that is speaking
of we really haven't talked about I know
how are you feeling about tomorrow one
more midnight actually no last night was
last midnight without midnight it's like
it's like tonight honestly I feel like
I don't know what we're getting because
usually we'll get like two three singles
we've gotten nothing so like I don't
know is she releasing a country album
like I have literally no idea what to
expect I don't even know what genre it
is so it feels um like there hasn't been
that much promo so I'm not
um it's not like top of mind for me even
though like I will be listening to it
first thing midnight I just like it
hasn't really settled for me yet like
that this is the reality you know yeah I
feel like I'm I keep thinking about it
because I keep doing things that require
me to listen to an album and I'm like is
midnight out yet this would be a good
time yesterday I made muffins for Olivia
and Kayla and Shapiro too so sweet I
really had Olivia and Kayla in mind and
I could have been listening to midnights
but no I was one day too early no I know
it's like just give us the album I've
had enough with these wait times like
and these videos like
I know it's like enough if we haven't
even gotten a single like I thought we
would for sure last week have gotten a
single and no you saw that she posted
like her planner yes with the what's
dropping and there's gonna be like a
challenge a music video a tick tock
challenge oh did I didn't say that like
the title of the song challenge
there's also a music video for anti-hero
um
yes that's us literally anti-heroes new
favorite song new and 100 new Anthem
it's the anti-anthem I'm so excited
um but again it's just like hard to get
excited like give me some like I like
great you're telling me the schedule of
what you're going to do the album that
you're going to release I need it I
can't get excited until it's here
honestly I agree and the I think the
promotion has been just like kind of
weird with like
her oh I disagree I think like she's
done a good job these like videos and
she always wearing the same outfit in
every video no it just looks like she is
every video is like full of different
Clues
interesting
um I very much enjoyed the red Taylor's
version era like I've been still in it
since it came out like I listened to it
this weekend so I will miss that I'm
ready for a new era I'm ready for new
music but again it's so hard to get
excited about something I know nothing
about agreed though it is red season
right now
I know but like the vibe that I get is
that it's not going to be like Autumn
girl Vibes see that's the thing I think
that is most artists with most artists
you're getting an album you know like
the vibe is going to be like pop you
know it's going to be rap you know
country with Miss Taylor like we could
get anything I know I think based on the
vibe and also like her career where
she's going I think it's going to be
like autumnal Vibes I think it's going
to be a little less Moody than folklore
and Evermore but a little less pop than
red say I agree by the way with that and
I think her hair is indicating that it's
not far from the red era
that's the hair is a great indicator of
what's to come
that's my theory okay we'll have a
listening party at midnight at my place
Jackie I'll meet you at midnight
okay ready for our next story but like
not if you're gonna be like a negative
naysayer like you sometimes are you know
when it comes to Taylor not about her
music okay I've never been because it's
what could I say I could learn Talent is
talent talent is Talent are you ready
for our next story
yes ma'am some surprising news I want to
get your thoughts on the movie rust will
resume production but not in New Mexico
Russ the movie That was supposed to
start Alec Baldwin before he
killed someone
um accidentally production in January
more than a year after cinematographer
Helena Hutchins was shot and killed on
set but the production will not return
to New Mexico where a criminal
investigation in state workplace safety
proceedings remain unresolved the
production is still looking for a new
location but California is a possibility
the production company announced a
settlement on October 5th with Matthew
Hutchins the widower of the
cinematographer under the agreement that
production will be able to resume after
a 15-month Hiatus Matthew Hutchins said
in a statement that completing the film
would be a way to pay tribute to
Helena's final work
some of the people who are working on
the set are looking forward to finishing
the project and also then submitting
Helena's work for uh nominations for
cinematography others who worked on the
movie like want nothing to do with it
anymore at this point yeah I mean I was
gonna say this is weird until it's clear
that's what her family wants so I think
they should respect what her family's
wishes are but I can't imagine first of
all that this is like a movie that
absolutely has to be made it's not
um like I like
I just feel like we need to let this
whole thing end like it's a terrible
chapter but it's what her family wants
it's what her husband wants so we just
have to respect it but um I think it's
weird
I think it's weird too I mean he did
settle with the production company so
maybe like part of the settlement is
like don't
we'll give you whatever sum of money but
like don't stand in the way of us
finishing this movie yeah yeah so maybe
how much money has already gone into the
movie I think the bigger question is is
like who wants to see who's going to
watch us
Nary a soul could you think of anything
else while watching it no I mean I
didn't think really anyone was going to
see an indie Alec Baldwin film before
this and now after I can't imagine
anyone is gonna wanna watch it's too
upsetting yeah
so I found that surprising news of the
day I find that surprising too like I
honestly it didn't even the thought
never popped into my mind like I wonder
if they're gonna finish this movie like
no the minute movie's done yeah
I just assumed it would never how can
these people get back like they all
witnessed something horrible right like
an innocent woman lose her life in
something that was so easily avoidable
aren't they traumatized like from
working on any movie Set let alone the
one where it happened yeah this is
really bizarre really and like kind of
sick
yeah
that's [ __ ] weird man agreed
are you ready for our next story yes a
little more filming news
um the crown is coming out in a few days
yes oh we'll watch it together
can't wait and there are storylines that
are circulating that are in the show
this season that did not happen in real
life and Judy Dench is calling on
Netflix to add a disclaimer to the crown
as fiction she said this cannot not Judy
Dench Judy Den she published a letter in
the times on Wednesday to Netflix saying
that they should add a disclaimer to the
Royal drama which returns for its fifth
season next month advertising itself as
a quote fictionalized drama the closer
the drama comes to our present times the
more freely it seems willing to blur the
lines between historical accuracy and
crude sensationalism given some of the
wounding suggestions apparently
contained in the new series that King
Charles plotted for his mother to
abdicate for example is one story line
that they put in that did not happen or
that he once suggested his mother's
parenting was so deficient that she
might have deserved a jail sentence Dame
Judy denge said this is both cruelly
unjust to the individuals and damaging
to the institution they represent no one
is a greater believer in artistic
freedom than I but this cannot go
unchallenged despite this week stating
publicly that the crown has always been
a fictionalized drama the program makers
have resisted all calls for them to
carry a disclaimer at the start of each
episode she said the time has come for
Netflix to reconsider for the sake of a
family and a nation so recently bereaved
as a mark of respect to a sovereign who
served her people so dutifully for 70
years and to preserve their own
reputation in the eyes of their British
subscribers wait this is so weird yeah
because it's been my understanding like
that
none of it was fictional thus far like I
thought it was as accurate of a
retelling as we're ever gonna get
it's my understanding that it's mostly a
retelling but that they do take creative
license and I think that
even though it should be sort of
inverted because the people are still
alive today who they're now talking
about I think like when the history
books have been written about something
from
almost 100 years ago they're able to
tell that story really easily but I feel
like in modern day like the history
hasn't been written so they're kind of
throwing their hat in the ring like how
about this version of events and they
keep saying what do they know they keep
saying we always tell like we never have
said that this is a true story but like
you're working with real people these
people are still alive
and it's such an influential show I
don't know that they need a disclaimer
obviously they can do whatever they want
I'm saying as a viewer like I
don't like this like I would rather it
be I want the truth I want the truth duh
no I'm like disappointed by this I'm
like wait has everything I didn't even
realize up until this point that it was
considered a fictional
retelling of History like I just thought
it was like they're doing their best to
find out what happened and I'm trusting
them to do that like that's what I
thought the whole time yeah well the
thing is I read a lot of historical
fiction books and they are fiction even
though they're based on real people
because it's like they don't know the
conversations that happen we're writing
those in we don't know what people were
thinking we're gonna
put our two cents in there right it has
to be considered a bit of fiction
because it's like obviously not exactly
what happened but if you're having whole
ass storylines that didn't happen there
that's different and it's yeah no and
it's really it's so recent that like
it's it's touchy it's and these people
are still alive like Charles is king now
and like I think there's a lot of
reasons to just like Charles but I don't
want a fake one to be the reason why I
no same I only like to dislike People
based on [ __ ] they actually did not [ __ ]
they didn't do right so
no I don't like this at all like this
this is murky for me I don't even think
like a disclaimer would change anything
you know because this show really
influences how people see the crowd and
I can say that because it's influenced
it made me interested in serial family
to begin with and so I don't like even
knowing that it's fictionalized like
doesn't change like how you leave
feeling the show and like who you are
and who you don't agree and I just don't
I wish they would just stick to the fact
no this sucks sucks and good on Judy
Dench for standing up for what she
believes in we have a scrupled a scruple
Dame and it's like if the world the
royal family would never address the
show they don't publicly address it and
I think that's fine it's like who could
speak out to Netflix and the show
producers that would make people listen
Dame Judy Dench yeah so Maggie Smith
Elton John
you know
yeah I saw Tick Tock people were like
legitimately quaking because they found
out do you know where Elton John lives
no
Atlanta
isn't that funny like yeah people would
like they were like I literally thought
he lived in a castle in you know
Cheshire of course or Los Angeles no he
lives not I would never even think he
lives in La like to me he's so London
I'm like he definitely lives in Big Ben
like he lives in Atlanta
maybe a castle in Atlanta for sure I'm
sure a palace I thought I saw him at the
Spritz meet and greet I saw him too by
the way you know he sent something in
the Box it was really sweet yeah and he
came up to him and he said hey Jax I'm
still standing better than I ever did
I can't think of that song without
thinking of Michaela now because that's
like the the Shapiro family's favorite
performance from that movie sing sing
one the gorilla who's voiced by Taryn
Edgerton a true Talent he goes I'm still
standing in bed and he really defies his
family because he comes from a criminal
family and he doesn't go into the family
business he Pursuits his dreams you'd
love to see it also Taron egerton who
also played Elton played yeah I love
that yeah that that character Arc of
like going from playing a gorilla to
playing Elton John
go back to playing a gorilla right sing
to
anyways this is just a fun reminder that
the crown is coming out and that I know
that we should now have to take it with
a grain of salt and all this time we
needed to take it with a grain of salt
and Dominic West is playing Prince
Charles which I was really really
against I did recently see the Downton
Abbey movie where he plays you know
someone from like that
who lives in who's living in London and
I do think it was like a good way to
digest
um
Dominic West as a character in that sort
of environment because it didn't bother
me that much actually loved his
character
um so I'm I'm looking forward to it even
though this definitely makes me question
I'm questioning every plot yeah every
episode which I didn't want to have to
you know no I didn't want to have to
either high alert after yes so annoying
so annoying someone should already have
the article written up of like this is
what is true from the season yes yes
free idea click bait
are you ready for our next story yes you
know it's um happy anniversary to news
to a Hollywood couple that is
long-standing
Justin Timberlake Praises Jessica Biel
on their 10-year anniversary I'm so
suspicious of him like I know well he
wants to be with Jessica Biel Until the
End of Time the happy couple celebrated
10 years of marriage on Wednesday by
posting a series of snaps from the last
decade to Instagram quote 10 years ain't
enough he said you make me a better
husband and father every day I love you
so much you beautiful human run it back
run it back
um I mean I guess this like would be
cute if it weren't for those New Orleans
photos like for me that's something I
think about all the time like him and
Jessica Biel like their story was like
kind of like really cute until it wasn't
because they just like got married and
became so normal together like have a
normal family like they're really not
thirsty anymore like they just are like
a happy family until he went to New
Orleans and worked on a project and was
walking around town holding hands with
some woman and then like we never got
any sort of follow-up to that you know
and now they're fine
yeah that's a good point I had forgotten
about that I was just like thinking I
never forget me stuff elephants never
forget no the Brittany stuff like okay
yeah we watched all these documentaries
where like Justin Timberlake is the
villain of the early 2000s like I oh I
am unique in the sense that like I
believe in growth and I I want to
believe that Justin Timberlake is like a
dad now and wouldn't be like that prick
that he was like I I believe people can
change like I don't think I'm not gonna
assume the Justin Timberlake who broke
up with Brittany and then did the Janet
thing is the Justin Timberlake he is now
like I'm just not gonna believe that
um but like two years ago you were being
weird and cheating on your wife like
let's talk about that
yeah
okay so it's really not sweet I was just
about to say how even though like we
brag on Justin Timberlake like like 10
years in Hollywood both is a lot like
that is an accomplishment
but you know not without I'm gonna I'm
gonna change my perspective you know not
without bumps and obstacles along the
way yeah I like always forget that these
two are married which is I guess like a
good thing
um I just like forget about Jessica Biel
in general you know like as a human
being I forget about her existence well
I think it might be by Design
you know I think like she's taken a huge
step back
I think she's like really passionate
about motherhood and family and like
that's awesome so like sometimes I just
forget
yeah I always forget about them because
I don't subscribe to him or his work I
hate him and it's like Mr Shoe energy
that it's giving Mr Shoe I just I have
to protect my peace I nobody understands
that better than me inner peace is so
hard to come by and once you do you
can't let anything infiltrate it so
sometimes we have to block Justin
Timberlake on social media and that's
okay but I thought that I would
celebrate this wonderful account
publishment today I would come crawl out
of my hole to keep Praise on the on this
milestone for them I'm happy for them
it's real nice it's real nice
okay are you ready for our fifth and
final story
already yeah already and it's not a
story it's um it's some fun zodiac
activities
what is no
here's your house of the Dragon
character based on your zodiac sign okay
yeah of course yeah okay should I just
go straight to yours and then I'll tell
everyone else is theirs yeah I'm a
cancer yes as a cancer you are viserys
Targaryen of all the characters I don't
really feel like that's a good one at
all actually let's just wait till you
hear mine of all the characters in House
of the Dragon viserys is a deeply
sensitive heart and is loyal to his
family both of them being the targaryens
and the high Towers he's extremely
focused on tradition uh sounding more
and more like you although is willing to
change things up when he names rhaenyra
his Heir he is compassionate forgiving
loving and loving always eager to defend
his family at all costs no for sure
desire to see them all United as one
house is an overwhelming motivation
for sure I just feel like he's missing
like the core for me at least when I you
know talk to the other cancers at our
monthly meetings I feel like a
Cornerstone quality of being a cancer is
like being able to Dish it and not take
it you know like that's what everyone
like that's really I think like how a
lot of cancers identify like being
really really rough but also like kind
of soft on the inside and I don't see
that for viserys at all like I wish he
would have been more rough interesting I
think the way that they just described
him describes you but I think if we read
it that's just Horrors if we read all of
the blurbs we would identify with them
what's yours you're a Sagittarius
correct hurtful sorry Scorpio I get the
S is confused and I unfortunately am
Otto Hightower
oh shh as hand of the king Otto
Hightower is one of the most strategic
characters in House of the Dragon he is
calculated and cunning just like the
Zodiac sign Scorpio he is also unafraid
to lurk in the shadows and keep his
actions private this gives him great
power as he Maneuvers for the throne
it's so sad I'm so sorry that that
happened to you so sad but I also I
don't identify as a Scorpio
and I've said this even before they told
me I was Otto Hightower like okay people
describe Scorpios really is not me how
do people describe them like like
passionate crazy like so like fiery and
like fired up and it's just like
that's not it that's not you I'm gonna
pull up a Scorpio description because
you're just extremely deep and emotional
people and are intense in all things
that they do they're natural leaders and
can be very serious okay maybe uh
Scorpios are one of the most interesting
signs because of their intensity yeah
like that's the thing like they're like
[ __ ] crazy no that's really like
you're not any of the things that they
just described right so I don't identify
as Scorpio every time I say that and
then someone says like well what's your
moon rising and I'm like and this is
where I have to exit the conversation
and this is where I have to go like back
to reality goodbye but for everyone
listening I'll let you know which house
of the Dragon character you are yeah
yeah Ares you are that's Ben Damon no
wonder you love him so much
yay Taurus that Zach Allison and Margo
power and Margo Margo Margo's such an
Allison oh my God totally oh my God
Gemini okay actually by the way viserys
being a cancer knowing that Olivia
ashrae is a cancer that makes sense
yeah
Gemini I I'm just glad I'm not this one
Laris strong
who's that foot man
yikes can service Leo Eamon Targaryen
okay Virgo sir Kristen Cole yikes Libra
lucerus Luke Valerian the kid how do you
even know the kid yeah these two no
that's a stretch Scorpio Otto Hightower
Sagittarius aegon Targaryen Capricorn
just saris Jace
Valerian the other kid
Aquarius princess rhaenyra that's Harry
Harry's an Aquarius
oh my God obsessed and what was the
character Rainier
yeah
queen queen
Who Never Was
Who Never Was and that's our fifth and
final piece of information that you
needed to know today I feel considering
you know it's a Thursday and we want to
get into the TV recap
oh my God Theo was hard
he's literally just standing there
looking at me hard he's ready for his
weekend with Bryce
the [ __ ] what's going on
that's so weird
he's fired now it's like a little
lipstick I when when dogs get hard it
freaks me out
you stop saying that he's hard
erect is that better red rocket six to
midnight
um
yeah half chap when you think of half
chap what do you think of three two one
yeah okay good
um Show's not over yet because we still
have a ton of TV recap let's dive into
part two of The Real Housewives of
Beverly Hills reunion was sponsored by
framebridge the Custom Framing company
framebridge will change your opinion on
what true customization really is they
measure and handcraft each frame
specifically for your piece so you can
frame Bridge just about anything selfies
Game Day Jerseys your anniversary dinner
menu a latest artistic masterpiece
here's how it works go to
framebridge.com and upload your photo if
you have a physical photo to frame you
can actually send it into them they'll
send you complimentary packaging so that
you can safely mail it in which is so
nice then you'll preview your items in
dozen of dozens of frame styles choose
your favorite or get free designer help
the experts at framebridge custom frame
your item and deliver your finished
piece right to your door
instead of paying hundreds at a framing
store framebridge starts at 39 plus free
shipping you can order online or stop by
a framebridge store near you to work
with a designer in person framebridge is
so genius because they're really
bringing the framing industry into the
21st century I feel like framing is such
an Antiquated business and it's so
expensive like for nothing
um and the sheer fact that you can
literally be on your phone and upload
photos directly from your camera roll
because some of the most photos I've
ever taken are just on my iPhone so
being able to frame those photos whether
it's photos of myself my family Theo
um a gorgeous artistic photo that I'm
like damn this should get some Jackie O
flow and like really be hung in an art
gallery it's really sickening I know
that you have like a framed photo of
yourself in your closet that you just
frame bridged right yes I do it's one of
my most highly valuable pieces of Art
and I'm looking into framing another
photo of myself maybe a photo that I
took I need some new art on these walls
and I'm obviously going to framebridge
because
it's like that's why we live in the 21st
century for right like brain wage that
we don't have to go to the frame where
we don't have to like haul these big
things around because framebridge does
everything it's fabulous and you can
frame your photos or send someone the
perfect holiday gift at framebridge.com
that's
f-r-a-m-e-b-r-i-d-g-e.com
framebridge.com check it out
all right part two and part one of the
Real Housewives of Beverly Hills were
really interesting to me because I feel
like in a weird way was really
highlighting how toxic the Bravo fandom
can be like the the way that they spend
so much time talking about like the
death threats all of their kids got of
course the attacks on Jacks the way that
all the women just like deal with this
hate it's so not normal and I know
they're like trying to get down to the
bottom of like you know why it started
and who threw hooved under the bus first
but like the way that they really need
to address the viewers directly like
remember when Bachelor Nation had to
literally that's what it was reminding
me of when like speak directly to the
people watching and be like you guys are
not okay like to message anyone at this
level let alone their kids for a TV show
that you watch it you absolutely need to
stop watching the show and you need to
go outside and touch grass like you're
not okay they need to do that because
like I don't even know if that Bachelor
thing did anything
I don't know that it did but I do think
it helps the cast and the talent like
feel supported support their Network and
not just like they're being exploited
for this TV show and then left to fend
for themselves I don't think it will
really change anything other than the
fact that now I feel like I'm more aware
of it I have a more like sympathy and
compassion Sympathy for the women like
even the ones that I don't agree with
it's like no one deserves that and it's
like that it's insane this discourse of
even just like disagreeing with people
if that's like what the road that we're
all headed down then uh apparently we
can't even disagree because like
that should never be happening I
personally I don't think Diana bought
those Bots I kind of don't either but
like who did well so they were saying
like Rina and Erica like really think it
was like designed to come between the
group and like it's some like
other being like this big like and like
an entity that's like trying to start
stuff but like
how do we know it's not just like a
bunch of [ __ ] losers making new
accounts like no that's a good one crazy
and also like just regular crazy ass
viewers trying to start [ __ ] within the
women like thinking that they can saying
leave Diana alone it's like okay now I
have garcelle again saying I'm gonna
write here you know no that's a good
point influence the storyline because
they don't have a life
no that's a good point too
um yeah I don't disagree that like it
doesn't feel right to just put it on
Diana because like at the end of the day
all these women are mothers and I don't
think they would really ever like attack
Someone's Child like I have to believe
that so everything that Diana said last
night like if she was lying about and
she did hire those bats okay then she's
a true psychopath I don't know her to be
one yet so I'm going to believe what she
said she is doing an investigation she's
putting all of her resources towards
this I have every reason to believe her
yeah even though like she's not perfect
by any means and you know the stuff with
trying to get her name penciled out of
Jax's post file it's all
yeah she was being like a little
delusional but but she did that I don't
I I don't disagree I think
um
what was really pissing me off from last
night's episode was crystal continuing
to say that's my truth Your Truth does
not equal the truth and I feel like that
was just her the way that she came up
with to like get out of being caught
telling all these lies yeah no I feel
like this is an inflection point because
my supplement saying that's my truth is
a statement that we all tolerate and
that we accept and it's like okay that's
how you experienced it like that's your
truth but seeing this happen in this way
just like made me realize that that is
not a thing no like they're there's you
can experience your feelings that's my
feeling and you can have your like
perspective and how you experienced a
thing but whether or not this thing
actually occurred that's not up for
debate no and like the word truth needs
to be reinstated for things that are
true yeah you know so it was really
interesting to like watch this all play
out last night and I'm like oh this
phrase of my truth is like really
problematic because like there's the
truth and everything else is is
important too your feelings and how you
perceive things and how you experience
your perception yeah call it any sort of
Truth when it's not
no it's such a it's such a manipulation
of words and for Miss word Smith over
there she's uh she's big with the word
important word that we shouldn't lose
you know we've lost a lot of words we
literally said like you know the phrase
like I'm literally dead and I'm dead
yeah you're not even laughing yeah I
think the word truth needs to be
reinstated as just the truth yeah no
because it's
and honestly like I could see Kyle's
like wheels just being like what is
going on in front of me because she
really they did call Crystal out like
because she made up this whole thing but
then on watch Happens Live she went and
said that there was something else there
was something worse but then Crystal
admitted on the reunion that there
wasn't like a thing it was more of a
tone but then they're like well so what
thing were you talking about on what
shop inside like she's just getting
caught in the size she looks so bad yeah
she looks so bad and it really I'm glad
that I think it was dorit who actually
brought it back and it was like you
started down this path because
garcelle's said that you were going to
call something out no matter what she
said and honestly Crystal told this
whole situation she created does prove
just that it validates everything
garcelle was saying but yeah Crystal did
not come off great
in the first two parts
and sudden I felt really good that she
got some sort of indication from
everyone for being Lisa rinna's punching
bag and I didn't think Lisa Rinna was
particularly genuine I just don't think
she's like a super genuine person so it
must have been nice just to like have
all the women like be there to
acknowledge like Lisa Rinna saying she
was sorry I did feel like when she was
talking about the glue thing it kind of
pissed me off when to read like I think
dorit was trying to embarrass
Sutton when she was like can you explain
like the glue thing so that all the
women could like laugh at Sutton or her
silly Southern sayings and then I was
like no you're just dumb
yeah I feel like I didn't think she was
trying to embarrass that and I feel like
she was like just playing until she was
trying to make like a moment like an
airhead moment yeah and like I didn't
like that because like leave Sutton
alone like I find myself extremely
protective of Sutton I know and it's
nice that all the women were there to
witness apology but I'm sorry it's too
little too late like no one had Suttons
back they allowed no one really be and I
don't accept garcelle I don't use this
word lightly bullied bullied yeah we all
sat around and it's been two seasons now
when everyone who comes in goes straight
for Sutton and no one has her back
except for garcelle so like I don't and
then garcelle gets in trouble for having
her back right and then what happens is
is the viewers
have have sentenced back yes and then
the women come around
100 seeing something I and we said this
before I think sometimes when you're in
something you can't see it and I'm sure
watching some of these situations might
change how the women like saw what they
experienced
um so I think that helps too but you
weren't there when it counted and who
cares now garcelle's story about Bill
Cosby was crazy crazy I didn't know that
now I really want to read her book you
should I should
um
and then what was the other thing that a
lot like the the book it thrown in the
book of the trash
as much as Rina and Erica are
problematic problematic I do admire
their friendship they really of course
but so why is it not a problem when they
do it but like Sutton and garcelle it's
a problem it's not a problem for me I
admire their friendship
so much not a problem for me but yes it
is a problem for the other women but
just the fact that and then they're
talking about like a group chat they
don't even have [ __ ] about their
Recycling and it wasn't even a video
yeah but you know what actually I'm sure
for Erica getting [ __ ] about recycling
is a welcome change 100 of all of her
comments are about like her not
recycling properly she would prefer that
to like her being
a master
100 widows and orphans yeah
um obviously like we're all waiting with
baited breath for Kathy
personally like I don't really like it's
been good but like I'm ready I need
Kathy I wish they had brought her in at
the end of last night's episode like I
needed something yeah and Lisa like
walking around like all I have to do is
tell the truth she's so self-righteous
producer but she looks like she's
talking to herself and going crazy yes
she does
um
I do you think Arena will be back next
season
so Kathy Hilton said on the red carpet
she's like I will not return if it's the
exact same cast the guy asking the
questions was like you're talking about
Rena
she was like yeah so she's she's
withholding her she doesn't need this
job so she's like yeah I'll come back if
rina's gone but if not I'm not going to
come
um and I can't imagine that they would
let Kathy go not only because she's
Kathy but also because the fans adore
her and they hate Rena yeah
I also wonder if garcelle's Gonna Come
Back
I know it feels like she's like so
damaged by the Jax thing and she like
doesn't even care to get into it with
all these other women because like it
got too real for her it's it was she's
so disturbed by what happened it's like
okay if my role on this show is causing
this to my children then like it's not
worth it no and I I I don't know if she
will come back I know
she seems like investigation bears fruit
and she can like
know who did it
and there will be Justice maybe then but
I don't know if she she does seem like
checked out
yeah because like it's too real now like
wow talk about how you said this about
this when like my kid minor is getting
these death threats and is being
harassed on his first day of school like
I don't care what happened also this
should be a lesson to every single woman
who comes on this show like it's fun to
have your kids on for sure honestly all
your kids should be private on social
media you should not put them on the
show no matter how old they are honestly
because nothing good comes of it like
for real like this should be a real
lesson to everyone who is already on the
show who plans on joining these
franchises like the fans are not okay
and this is what I feel like we're
always saying about Bravo fans like
there's a corner of the Bravo universe
that's like so unhinged and it's really
scary to put your kids in that it really
is yeah the only thing you said nothing
good comes from it but I think a lot of
people have seen some good come from it
from somebody like Gia Gia I mean
obviously uh like Amelia and Delilah
Gigi yeah yeah and so I think that if
that's what your kid wants to do then it
is a good platform for them but like
knowing what comes with it is you pay
you do pay a price of course and so but
I think if you're just like showing your
kid because your kid is cute and like
we're just having a good time I don't
think it's worth
being cast under the spotlight I agree
and also it's really not my favorite
content unless like unless it's Carlin
like
that the truth yeah is on my favorite
content oh speaking of Carlin Salt Lake
City Housewives is so bad uh they
finished up this turn trip that was
supposed to be like a retreat for Jen
Jen goes to New York by herself
to prepare for trial
um and all the other women just like
lose their [ __ ] minds like they just
they once again like there's so much
going on now Whitney and Heather are at
each other at each other's throats for
the dumbest reason what does it start
with why are they at each other's
throats so Whitney brings up this rumor
that she heard about Lisa Barlow the
rumor came from Angie they were out to
dinner with Angie Utah named Angie
no it's the same Angie no but like
there's been Angie last season there's
new Angie
there's new Angie she's like a new
housewife they had a party at her house
oh yeah is her name Angie yeah and then
there were two Angies before her
oh so I wonder what Angie they're
talking about actually no I don't know
um well Whitney said that we were out to
dinner with Angie me and Heather and she
told us this rumor that Lisa Barlow
gives blow jobs for Courtside Utah Jazz
tickets and
Heather's like I have no idea what
you're talking about like I do not know
what like that rumor and so they're like
fighting about whether or not
Heather knows that rumor and then I
really was believing Heather that she
didn't know that rumor until they like
later in the night she was like if I
hear something and choose to not
register it or spread it or just ingest
it that's okay too and like that is
totally okay but so did you hear it or
did you not you know
well in her defense one I agree with her
if I hear something I choose not to
register like that's okay that's her
prerogative
if she had said that she even heard the
rumor and just acknowledged like yes
that truly that she did then it's like a
real thing it gives it's not just like
one person made some [ __ ] up it's like
oh there's this rumor going around and
multiple people have heard it so I
actually think
by like not even saying that she heard
it it's a kindness
you know and by the way like I think
Heather's just trying to work on her why
don't you Lisa that doesn't like I'm not
feeling like she lied like I feel like
No And so but but
Whitney is taking it as like a huge
betrayal like you throw your back on
your family like Whitney's so not okay
she's so all over the place like these
entire last three years I like never
keep up with her and a huge part of her
storyline is like now diving into her
childhood trauma and like I'm really
happy that she's going on this healing
journey and I'm not trying to be mean
but like I really don't care
no I I know it's a hard line to walk and
and it always surprised me what I do
care about you know yeah like what
people share something that they've
never shared before and I'm like oh my
gosh wow this is so compelling like
Jackie Goldman Jackie gold Schneider
Jackie I was gonna say the same thing
but then sometimes people share
something you've never shared before and
are going through it and I'm like why
are you doing this with cameras like and
like I don't care talking to like you
know people from your childhood who
haven't had this conversation with and
like why am I there too
her long-lost siblings like she has half
siblings like that's why they're in
Arizona she actually goes and spends the
day with them and they're lovely people
and they all are on this beautiful
healing journey and I could knock out
Claudia there
beats me
and then in the most recent episode of
tell me lies I won't spoil anything for
you but like my God it was so [ __ ]
infuriating to watch but like you really
see the full minute like you see should
I take my headphones off and you could
just talk to people because I don't even
want to like be sure sure
okay I don't really have a lot to say
you guys but like the sheer fact that
like Stephen come like he goes to visit
me he goes to visit Macy's like
accident site and he realizes like he's
literally responsible
and the one girl who knows he's
responsible uh
he's being mean too so he like runs back
and tells her that he loves her and like
honestly it's like so manipulative and
sad when she's like on the floor of the
of the dorm room like having a [ __ ]
panic attack and he just comes back and
tells her that he loves her like when he
obviously doesn't
um also Justice for pipa I never thought
I would say that because like she's
really been pissing me off but like
she's getting blamed for the letter and
it wasn't her and Wrigley broke up with
her like that was so sad even though
like Wrigley loves her and she doesn't
even like him so like it's probably for
the best but it did make me really sad
because
Wrigley
ended up in the hospital and broke up
with his girlfriend and it wasn't even
pippa's fault all right that's all I
have to say Jax you're good
you put your headphones back on great I
think that was good because even if you
were like it was so crazy he was so
crazy I'd be like I'll be like waiting
for the crazy yeah no no you're right
you're right you're totally right oh
take off oh so no no because it's
totally like an innocuous storyline but
like one of the characters gets in like
trouble with school like for something
they did on like homework okay and it
honestly gave me like PTSD oh I'm sure
that was the worst like in college like
when you like almost got in like a lot
of trouble
yeah you know I need to know what
happened but it's not important like for
real okay cool
um so that is our show I'm literally
gonna upload this episode and head to
the airport I'll see you soon girly tell
brodini his auntie is coming for him I
can't wait to see you and tomorrow we'll
be reunited in Florida with the
flamingos
thank you guys so much for listening to
the toast the millennial Morning Show
where we deliver the fast five stories
that you need to know every Monday
through Friday on YouTube so if you're
watching this on YouTube please feel
free to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up we're also available podcast
anywhere podcast Republic
about a beautiful Sunday it's where we
are hope you guys have been in crap
Thursday we'll see you tomorrow for
Friday Friday gotta get down on Friday
redheads merch is live now
shopmorningtoast.com and if this
episode's ending but you need more
content to get through the day head over
to patreon.com slash the toast we've got
some premium content for you and more is
on the way bye